JOHN DAY-RICHTER: All right,
hello, ladies and gentlemen,
and thank you for attending take
two of introducing the
Google Drive SDK.
Thanks for being here.
I'm John Day-Richter, I'm the
tech lead for the Google Drive
SDK, and this is my
very good friend--
JOSH HUDGINS: I'm Josh Hudgins,
I'm the product manager.
JOHN DAY-RICHTER: All right,
well, thanks for coming out.
We're going to tell you all
about the Google Drive SDK.
Take us through what we're
going to talk about.
JOSH HUDGINS: So here's what
we're going to do today.
First off, I just want to point
out that we do have free
T-shirts in the back, so--
[CHEERING]
JOHN DAY-RICHTER: Yeah,
that's right.
JOSH HUDGINS: Yeah.
So you know how we're going to
roll in this session today,
free T-shirts.
So the way we'll do it is we'll
have a little Q&A at the
end, and if you ask a really
awesome question, you're going
to have a T-shirt coming your
way, so look forward to that.
So here's what we're
going to cover.
First, we're going to talk a
little bit about Drive, what
it is as a product and why we
felt like an SDK is such a
critical part of Drive as a
product, and how you might use
it, why we built it,
that sort of thing.
Then we're going to talk through
what we launched in v1
of the SDK when we launched
Drive back in late April.
Then we're going to get to the
exciting stuff, the stuff that
we have just launched over the
last couple days, and then
some things that will be coming
down the pipe soon,
some stuff we're very
excited about.
So first, a little bit about
Drive and the SDK and why we
think the SDK is an important
part of the product.
So Drive itself, when I think
about Drive, I like to
describe it along three
main features,
or three main pillars.
You saw a little bit of this in
Clay's demo in the keynote,
but we'll kind of go through
this, and as we go through
these things you'll see why
overlaying an SDK over the top
of these things can be such
a powerful thing.
But the first pillar is this
idea of access anywhere, and I
think you saw that demonstrated
very well today.
No matter where you are, we have
given you access to the
content you have put in
Drive, so we do this
through a number of ways.
The first is through the web
UI at drive.google.com.
Everything in your drive is
available to you through any
web browser that we support, and
you can do everything you
need to do there through the
web-- you can share, you can
manage your files, you can
collaborate on them with
Google Docs, you can do a whole
number of things through
the web UI.
There's also the sync clients.
We have sync clients now for Mac
and Windows, and the sync
client is a really terrific
piece of software that you
install on your desktop machine,
and it's going to
sync content on your desktop
machine back and
forth to the cloud.
So changes you make locally will
be reflected back in the
cloud, and changes you make in
the cloud are broadcast back
down to your local machine.
So wherever you have these sync
clients installed, all of
your content will always be up
to date across all of your
different machines.
And we also have
mobile devices.
Native apps on mobile devices,
we just announced that the iOS
app is available today on iPads,
iPods, pretty much any
iOS device.
We have mobile devices on
Android, and now we also have
Drive integration built directly
into Chrome OS, so
virtually any device you're
working on you're going to be
able to access your content
there and interact with it in
meaningful ways.
The next thing is Drive
is really all about
collaboration.
It's not just about storing
things, it's about giving you
ways to work with other people
on the content in Drive.
So there's three main ways we
allow you to do this, and then
at the end of the presentation
we'll talk about some really
exciting things coming
in this space.
But the first one of these
things is sharing.
In Drive, we let you share
content with people for a
variety of different ways-- you
can make content public,
you can share content with large
groups of people through
an unlisted link, you can share
directly with other
Drive users--
just adding them directly to the
content, and then only you
and they can see it, or you can
even share it with groups.
And when you do that sharing,
it's not just a blanket share,
you can decide what kind of
things that person can do with
the thing you're sharing.
So I can say, for instance, if
I shared something with John,
I probably don't want to let
him edit my file, he's not
really that reliable,
so I would just
give him view access.
Whereas other people you could
give edit access, or even
access to add comments, and
comments is the very next
thing I want to talk
about here.
We now have given people that
use Drive the ability to add
comments to anything
in their drive.
In the past, you could do that
for Google Docs, but arbitrary
files you couldn't.
Now you can add comments to any
file at all in Drive, and
so you could work together in
your team and add comments to
things and collaborate on those
things all at once.
And the last thing I want to
talk about in terms of
collaboration is-- you saw
this today in the demo as
well-- is Google Docs,
of course.
Google Docs allows you to
collaborate on a level that's
virtually unique across
this space.
You can co-edit documents in
real time and everyone's
changes are automatically
broadcast to everyone else.
If I'm working with John on
a document, I can see
immediately the changes he's
making to the document, so
it's an incredibly powerful
tool for collaboration.
And then the last
thing is search.
And I think this also came
across very well in the demo
today as well.
If you talk about this for
images, it's a really cool
thing, every image that is
uploaded into Drive we run
through the Google Goggles back
end, which is the same
technology that powers Google's
visual search.
So this back end can recognize
a number of different things
in your images-- it can
recognize famous landmarks,
faces, corporate logos, and it
does a terrific job in doing
optical character recognition on
the content and the images.
So if you upload pictures
of mountains, or famous
landmarks, or buildings,
and you can
search for those things.
The demo we like to do is Mount
Everest, we just upload
a ton of different pictures from
users of Mount Everest.
No metadata at all associated
with the image-- no file
names, no Exif, no geotagging,
nothing.
And Google Goggles can identify
them as pictures of
Everest, it's really quite
amazing to see.
So all that power of search
right there in
Drive for you to do.
What we do then--
go ahead and click it--
is over the top of all of these
different services we
have overlaid in SDK, which
we're going to give developers
the ability to access all of
this technology, and John's
going to talk more about that.
JOHN DAY-RICHTER: So the Drive
SDK really cuts across all of
these three different pillars
of Google Drive, and makes
them available to
the applications
that you want to write.
And before we go into what the
Drive SDK does, we felt like
we needed to explain why we
built an SDK at all because we
know we are not the only game in
town, and other people have
SDKs too, but we felt like there
were some things about
our product that were so special
that it was important
for us to make an SDK so that
other people could start
writing apps on top of it.
So first of all, with Google
Drive we wanted to make sure
that it wasn't just a place to
keep stuff, we wanted to make
it a place to do stuff.
So no matter which of the Google
Drive clients you're
using, you can use your
file on that system.
So if you're using the Google
Drive web client, you can do a
whole lot more than just
download the files that are in
Google Drive.
Using Drive apps-- which you
heard a little bit about at
the keynote, and Josh is going
to show us an awesome demo of
in a second--
you can take your apps on the
web, and just edit them with
other web apps that
you've installed.
And if there's something that
you want to do on the web that
Google hasn't written a product
to handle, doesn't
matter because chances are
somebody else did and you can
use the file there.
Also, on our Android client you
can, of course, open your
files using any app that
you've got installed on
Android that can handle those
files, but if you want to use
a web app that you've installed
on the web, our
Android client can open your
file in that web app on your
mobile device.
And with the improvements that
we've made to our mobile API
if you don't want to have to
go through the hassle of
downloading your file and
handing it off to another app,
apps can be written that can
access Google Drive's data
store directly.
So there's a lot of ways to
continue to use your files
even when they're stored
on Google Drive.
And you can reach millions
of users.
Google Drive has a lot
of users, I can't
talk specific numbers--
it's more than two.
There's a lot of
guys out there.
And then you're not just getting
access to Google
Drive's users, you're getting
access to the entire Google
ecosystem of users via things
like OAuth login and all these
different mechanisms that will
bring Google users to your
app, if you build it on
top of Google Drive.
And we are really committed
to helping our developers
succeed, and there's a lot of
ways that we really think that
developers can do well
using this API.
So, for example, when--
like almost everything
at Google I/O--
when you use the Google Drive
APIs, you get access to the
entire world of Google APIs,
so it's really easy to
integrate calendar and
contacts, and all the
different stuff that we've
already got APIs for, it's
really easy to build that into
your app that's already
talking to Google Drive.
And Google Drive is all
integrated with Google Docs,
so lots of features that are
features of Google Docs become
ways of publicizing your app.
When you share a document that
was created with your app, the
user gets shared your app too,
or at least an opportunity to
install the app.
So your app can grow virally
just through users sharing
content and collaborating.
And then, finally, we wanted
to make sure that there was
really every mechanism to
publicize the work you've
done, so we've integrated with
the Chrome Web Store and
there's this entire store where
users can discover new
Google Drive apps and find
out more about what
you're working on.
Did I forget anything
there, Josh?
JOSH HUDGINS: I think you've
covered pretty much everything
in the preview.
JOHN DAY-RICHTER: So here's what
we've launched already--
what we launched before Google
I/O started-- and we wanted to
just do a brief overview.
So first, there's the
Google Drive API.
So we've completely rebuilt this
from the old Google Docs
List API, which is sort of
similar, but we built it as a
RESTful API--
credentials and authentication
are now based on OAuth 2--
far more modern--
and we've got client libraries
and code samples in six
different languages, so there
are really a lot of options to
build your app however
you want to.
JOSH HUDGINS: So as part of the
SDK v1, we also introduced
this concept of a Drive app.
So as we were building out Drive
we had built a viewer
that could give you read-only
views of between 30 and 40
different file types, many of
the major things people like
to view like PDFs, and Word
documents, and images, and
things like that.
We realized there was still this
entire constellation of
content that we just didn't
provide much of an experience
for, so what we wanted to do
was open up our UI to third
party developers, so they could
take an app that they
had already built that maybe
provided a nice experience for
a certain type of content and
integrate that app directly
into the Drive UI, and
so that's what Drive
apps are all about.
So you can build an app, and
then you basically tell us
what sorts of MIME types or
file extensions you can
handle, and once the user
installs that app, we
interweave that app into the
very fabric of the UI, so
everywhere you interact with a
piece of content of that type
users have the choice
of using the app of
yours that they installed.
We also offer you a neat option,
if you've already
built a web app that stores
content in its own back end or
some sort of proprietary system,
but you still want to
integrate with Drive, you don't
necessarily have to
store the content in Drive, you
can continue to store the
content in your own system and
then provide a pointer to it
in Drive, so users will see it
in their drive as if it were
any other type of item.
They can do things with it like
sharing, or manage it
within the Drive UI, so it's
pretty much like any other
item, but when you click on it,
it opens the content up
from your system, so you have a
lot of different integration
options depending on where
you're at as a web app.
JOHN DAY-RICHTER: And if you
write an app that handles a
type that already is handled
by Google Drive,
we're fine with that.
If you wrote a better viewer,
the user can choose to make
that the default, and they'll
use yours from now on.
JOSH HUDGINS: But the best thing
about it is is we give
users control over
the experience.
So if you provide a great
experience, we don't favor our
own in any way, so they can
build a customer experience
that makes sense for them.
And another thing that we've
done, I think, that makes the
development experience very
fulfilling here in Drive is
we've done a lot of great
integrations with
the Chrome Web Store.
So if you built an app that does
integrate with Drive, you
can list it and distribute it
through the Chrome Web Store,
and there's a lot of
great things that
come along with that.
It's a great mechanism for
discovery, so users can come
in through the Chrome Web
Store's front page, and then
find the Drive apps collection,
and if you had
integrated with Drive, your
app would show up there.
But not just promotion and
servicing and discovery
through the Chrome Web Store,
but we also link to the Chrome
Web Store all throughout the
Drive UI, we take tons of
opportunities to promote apps
in different scenarios where
it makes sense that will link
off to the Chrome Web Store so
users can make more avenues
to find and discover and
install your app.
So as part of the Chrome Web
Store, you also get a lot of
other things for free.
You get things like bug
reports, ratings,
reviews, and analytics.
And all these things-- great
feedback from your user
community--
all come for free as part of
being listed in the store, and
then maybe the best thing about
it now is it doesn't
just work for Chrome, despite
the fact it's called the
Chrome Web Store you can now
install Drive apps from the
Chrome Web Store
in any browser.
JOHN DAY-RICHTER: So the Drive
SDK also has some great
security features.
And we found that users are more
likely to use apps that
they trust, so if you have a
very scary security warning
when your app is installed,
users often walk
away at that point.
We've done everything we can
to make sure that your app
gets at the data that it needs,
but only the data that
it needs so that users aren't
scared off and there's less of
a danger of a user installing
an app that misbehaves.
So many people have asked, can
I do this thing with the
Google Drive SDK version one?
And I will say, no, you can't
do that, and they will say,
are you lazy?
And I will say, yes,
but that's not it,
it's actually a feature.
So with Drive apps in the SDK
version one, apps can only
access files that the app
created, or that the user
explicitly gave access to.
So if a user's installed your
app, your app still can't get
at their files until they choose
to open the file with
your app in Google Drive, and
that way if the user installs
an evil app, it's still only
being evil at one or two
files, and it's very easy in
the Google Drive UI to
uninstall apps and revoke
access to files for a
particular app if a user feels
like it's misbehaving.
And all of this is bringing
great peace of mind to our
suspicious web users.
And, finally, there's a file
picker here because we know
that a lot of apps need the
ability to have a user pick a
file from their corpus, and we
don't give you any way to do
that through the API.
So with this JavaScript
component, you can pop up a
view of the user's drive, served
from Google, so it's in
a trusted context from Google,
they choose the files that
they want to open with your app,
the picker grants access
to your app when the user
chooses it, and then your app
has access to the file.
So you can still make apps that
operate on any arbitrary
file in the user's corpus,
and it's very secure.
So it's demo time.
JOSH HUDGINS: OK.
JOHN DAY-RICHTER: Let's show
how all of this works.
JOSH HUDGINS: So what I want
to do is walk you through a
scenario where John
here is my boss.
JOHN DAY-RICHTER:
I'm the boss?
JOSH HUDGINS: Yep.
JOHN DAY-RICHTER: All right.
JOSH HUDGINS: And he has just
come up with a revolutionary
new idea for a software
product.
JOHN DAY-RICHTER: Hudgins!
I gots me an idea for
a software project.
JOSH HUDGINS: And so he is a
dedicated Microsoft Project
user, and he has shared with me
a Microsoft Project file.
So what I need to do is figure
out what he wants me to do,
and then do it, but the catch is
that I don't have access to
any of my local desktop
applications that I would
normally do, I have to figure
out how to do all this stuff
all from the cloud, all
in a web browser.
JOHN DAY-RICHTER: Hudgins, did
I just see you uninstall the
app so you can demo installing
the app?
JOSH HUDGINS: You may have
seen that very thing.
JOHN DAY-RICHTER: OK.
JOSH HUDGINS: So here's
the MPP file that
he shared with me.
Now, if I click on this in
Drive, Drive doesn't actually
preview this file, it's one of
the file types that Drive
doesn't do anything with, so I
have no preview, so without
Drive apps I would be
stuck right here.
But fortunately, we give you
this little icon down here
that says I can get more apps,
and what this is going to do
is open the Chrome Web Store and
show me all the apps that
are integrated with Drive that
can do something with
Microsoft Project.
So fortunately, we have three
different choices here I can
choose from, and I'm going
to install Gantter.
It's going to take me here, and
I'm going to hit Add To
Chrome, and that's going to
install it into Drive, and if
I go back here and hit Refresh,
you can see that my
project plan now has the Gantter
icon next to it, which
means when I click on
this, it's going
to open it in Gantter.
So I'm going to do that, and
it's going to ask for
permission to access my drive,
so this is our auth screen,
you can see all of
the different
things it wants to access.
I'm going to hit Allow
Access, and it's
going to open the file.
JOHN DAY-RICHTER: Hudgins,
where are we with
that project plan?
JOSH HUDGINS: Getting close.
So it's pulling the binary over
from Drive, and now it's
going to open it
and render it.
And using John's typical project
code words I can see
First Task here, I know
exactly what that is--
he needs me to create a
wireframe mockup of his great
new software idea.
JOHN DAY-RICHTER: Oh yeah, and
we're going to have buttons.
The kids love buttons
nowadays.
JOSH HUDGINS: So I need to
create this new product that
has more buttons than we
typically have, so
fortunately, I have an app
installed into Drive that can
do something like that.
I have an app called Balsamiq,
which allows me to create
mocks and wireframes, and
that sort of thing.
So I'm going to open that up,
and I'm going to start
designing this new product
that he wants to see.
And it's clear we're going to
need a lot of buttons based on
the feedback I've
gotten so far.
JOHN DAY-RICHTER: Make a button
so you can plus one
another button.
JOSH HUDGINS: So that's probably
a good amount of
buttons there.
So I'm going to save that, and
I'm going to call that the New
Button Design.
The cool thing about this is
when I save it, it doesn't
save a local copy of that file
down to my machine, it saves
it directly back to my drive.
So I can go back to my drive and
see it right here as New
Button Design.
So now I'm going to share that
back with John because he
needs to see it and make sure
that the buttons are numerous
enough and properly
positioned.
JOHN DAY-RICHTER: Oh, they
better be numerous.
JOSH HUDGINS: So I'm going
to share that.
And I believe John's [? MO ?]
email address is demo two.
Hit Share.
And so now when I switch over
to John's account, that will
show up here--
New Button Design.
So when I click on
that, he doesn't
have Balsamiq installed.
JOHN DAY-RICHTER:
What is this?
JOSH HUDGINS: But it tells him
that-- it knows that Balsamiq
created this file, so when he
tries to preview the file it
says, hey, you're going to need
Balsamiq to look at this,
and there's a button right here
to install it so he can
install it.
So we'll talk about this a
little bit more in a minute,
but this is just a great growth
channel for web app
install bases because as people
across these teams
start to share content they
create with these apps around
there are constant upsells all
through the UI to help users
find and discover apps they can
use to work together on
these things.
So what John would do then is
install that app and he would
be able to look at and
approve it and all
those different things.
So let's pretend
he's done that.
JOHN DAY-RICHTER: Oh, that's
a good design.
JOSH HUDGINS: Buttons
looking good?
JOHN DAY-RICHTER: Yeah,
buttons all right.
JOSH HUDGINS: So now we need to
get legal approval for this
thing, and our legal department
has some sort of
unusual requirements--
JOHN DAY-RICHTER: They need to
get the documents via fax
because that's what those
people understand.
JOSH HUDGINS: So apparently our
legal department has no
computers whatsoever and
they only receive
documents via fax.
And from long experience working
with these guys, I've
also learned that if I draw
a smiley face on the paper
before I fax it, they'll
tend to approve it.
The problem is I don't have a
printer, and I don't have a
fax machine.
But fortunately, I do have an
app that allows me to edit
images, but before we do that,
we need to save our mockup
back to Drive as an image.
So I can open the
mockup back up--
JOHN DAY-RICHTER: Hudgins,
is that contrived
example done yet?
Getting closer.
And I'm going to export that
to PNG, and we see the New
Button Design show up
right here in Drive.
I'm going to click on
it and make sure
everything's looking good.
There's the PNG, it looks
good viewing it in the
Google Drive Viewer.
So now I need to edit that
because it's going to have to
have a smiley face on it.
So I'm going to open that with
an image editor that I've
installed called Pixlr Editor,
and that will open up the
image and if you've used a lot
of image editing tools, this
is a fairly familiar
interface.
And I'm just going to draw
a smiley face right here.
Close enough.
JOHN DAY-RICHTER: Like
money in the bank.
JOSH HUDGINS: So now I'm going
to save that, and it's going
to save it back over
the original
file back in my drive.
That's saved, now let's go back
and make sure that my
smiley-- yep, everything's
looking good.
So now all I need to do
is fax this to legal.
I don't have a fax machine, but
what I do have is an app
called HelloFax that will
allow me to fax almost
anything in my drive
to a fax number.
So now I'm going to open
this PNG with HelloFax.
And what that's going to do is
start loading the document in
the background, and it's
going to ask me what I
want to do with it.
Well, I want to fax it.
I'm going to click that.
It's loading the document and
while it's doing that I'm
going to type a made
up fax number.
And you can see that the
document has been loaded here,
it's got my smiley face, its got
our design, and all I have
to do is hit Send It Now, and
it will fax that document
directly to our legal
department.
We managed to do all of that
without touching any local
software, or any hardware,
doing it
all through the cloud.
It's pretty cool stuff.
[APPLAUSE]
JOHN DAY-RICHTER:
Aww, thank you.
I don't have to do boss voice
anymore, I'll stop doing that.
Yeah, OK.
JOSH HUDGINS: All right, so now
I want to talk a little
bit about the value proposition
of this whole
thing from the developer's
point of view.
So if you decide to go down this
path of integration, what
is your cost to do it and what
type of return do you want to
see from that?
JOHN DAY-RICHTER: Is this
the money part?
JOSH HUDGINS: This might be
a little bit producty.
JOHN DAY-RICHTER: OK, I'll
translate for [? amateurs. ?]
Go ahead.
JOSH HUDGINS: So first is what
are you investing to do the
integration?
So in our experience working
with our partners, the
feedback we have gotten-- the
API is simple, it's very easy
to use, and we've had several
reports of partners that were
able to build their entire
Drive integration on an
existing web app in less than
24 hours, a couple of them
even talked about that directly
in their press release.
JOHN DAY-RICHTER: So guys, your
boss is going to be all
like, how long is it going to
take to do the Google Drive
integration?
And you'll be like, man, it's
only going to take a week.
And then you do it in a
day, and then you go
see Avengers, again.
JOSH HUDGINS: So your investment
is relatively
small, so what do you
get in return?
So you're going to get access
to two things we think are
very important.
The first is the Drive user
base, and you heard this
morning that Clay announced
we're already over 10 million
users after a couple months.
And pretty soon, you'll get
access not only to that user
base, but anyone, basically,
who has a Google account,
you'll be able to interact with
their drive in some way,
so that's a very large,
very active user base.
And then what we're going to
talk about more in just a
minute-- and I think Clay kind
of touched on this, we're
going to explore it in
more depth here--
is that the users you get as
part of a Drive integration
tend to be more engaged and more
active users, so that's
definitely something you're
going to want
in your user base.
JOHN DAY-RICHTER: Not
just more users,
they're better people.
JOSH HUDGINS: And we also give
you many opportunities to grow
your install base, it's
a great way to get
exposure for your app.
And as you saw in the demo, we
promote apps all throughout
the UI and virtually
anyplace users can
interact with files--
like the chip you saw in the
bottom left corner of our
viewer that helps you go to the
Chrome Web Store and find
apps specifically for
that type of file.
Every time users share files
created with apps, we give the
receiving user an upsell to
install your app if somebody
shared a piece of content with
them, and the CWS shift that
we mentioned before.
So all those things help you
give you new channels to grow
your install base, and is a
very nice return on this
relatively small investment.
So we're going to walk through
a couple case studies now and
kind of show you what that looks
like with actual numbers
from our partners.
JOHN DAY-RICHTER: Yeah.
JOSH HUDGINS: All right.
So first a SlideRocket.
So SlideRocket has a web-based
presentation editor that
allows you to create
presentations, and they store
the data in their own system.
They've been around for a while,
and already have a
relatively stable and large user
base, and they did their
Drive integration and launched
with us back in late April.
So since that time, 8 out
of their top 10 days for
registrations have come after
the Drive launch, so they've
seen incredibly accelerated
growth and installs because of
their Drive integration.
And then this really speaks--
this next point-- to this viral
growth channel that
happens when people start
sharing content they create
with Drive apps, over a quarter
of all their new users
since Drive launched have
originated from one user
sharing a SlideRocket
presentation with another
user, so it's a very powerful
channel for growth.
And when they compared Drive
users to their original
baseline non-Drive users
they found some
pretty surprising things.
Drive users were three times
more active, they logged in to
the product three times as
often, and they also created
over three and a half times
more presentations than
non-Drive users did.
JOHN DAY-RICHTER: See,
better people.
JOSH HUDGINS: So the next case
study is Lucidchart, which is
a flowchart and diagramming
tool.
They gave us two interesting
numbers that came out of their
analysis comparing their
original baseline users with
the new users that came as part
of the Drive integration.
So for them they had a very
interesting result, one of
them was that the users they
were getting via the Drive
channel tended to be more large
team-based enterprise
accounts, which for a piece of
software like this is a very,
very important metric for them
because that means it's going
to be higher retention rates,
better monetization, better
conversion.
So they're getting exactly the
users they want in larger
numbers because of the Drive
integration, and a large part
because the Drive integration
makes it so much easier for
their users to work in teams.
And then they saw something
very similar in terms of
engagement and document
creation, that Drive users
were creating three times as
many documents through
Lucidchart as their non-Drive
users were.
The last case study
is HelloFax.
And HelloFax measures user
engagement with two metrics.
One of them is how many faxes
are sent, and the other one is
how many documents are
sent per signature.
And they are seeing
significantly higher
engagement along both metrics
for the same comparison of
Drive users versus
non-Drive users--
26% more faxes and
twice as many
documents sent per signature.
So I think the data we're
getting back from the
developers and the people in
the ecosystem are pretty
significant, and that's that
when you do the Drive
integration it creates a much
richer environment for users
both to collaborate and to
create more content.
It's much more interactive
and there's a lot more
opportunities for you to
grow your install base.
JOHN DAY-RICHTER: So here is
what we're launching at Google
I/O. So first, the Drive API
version two, and it adds all
of the Drive operations that the
Drive UI can do, or that
the old Doc List API can do,
to the existing v1 API.
So it's the new RESTful API with
all of those different
languages we talked about
before, and OAuth 2 and all of
that stuff, but it can do
anything that you can do in
Google Drive.
And there are two levels of
access in the Drive API now.
So there's the level of access
I talked about before, where
your app can just get at files
that it created or were
granted access to the app--
and that works fine with
all operations--
so if you list files, you'll
just see the files that your
app has access to, so it filters
the view of Google
Drive based on what your
app has access to.
But if you've written the kind
of app that really needs
complete access to the user's
drive, you can write that too.
So if you want to write an
alternate client for Google
Drive, you have all the tools
you need to do it.
You will get a scarier message
at authentication time, of
course, but that's the price
of functionality.
And now there's no Drive app
required for API access.
That was true in the original
version of the API, not true
anymore, you don't have
to have an app at all.
And there are two new client
libraries available, so if you
want to write apps in JavaScript
or Objective-C
because say you want
to write--
well, you know what Objective-C
is for-- then
those libraries are available
to you to.
And we're improving the
mobile experience,
to my previous point.
So now you can launch Drive apps
right from the Android
Drive application.
So if there's a web app, you
can launch it right from
there, we talked about
that before.
As you heard earlier, we've
got an iOS app for Drive
nowadays, and although this
functionality isn't available
in that app, it's coming soon.
And you can open and save to
Drive from within mobile apps.
So if you want to write an app
that's not at all integrated
with the drive client, that's
fine, you can do that on iOS
or on Android mobile
devices right now.
And then finally the mobile
libraries are just a lot
easier to use.
With the new rebuilt APIs,
you'll find the whole
experience of developing for
mobile clients a lot smoother.
JOSH HUDGINS: So if you're
interested in writing any sort
of Drive integration on mobile,
we're going to have a
session later today at 4 o'clock
in Room Six where
we're going to walk you through
that process in a
whole lot more detail, so how
you would do Drive integration
on a mobile device.
JOHN DAY-RICHTER: Yeah, if it
turns out that I'm wrong about
it being easier, feel free
to punch me in the face.
JOSH HUDGINS: Deal.
All right.
So the next thing that we're
launching as part of this new
version of the SDK is the
embeddable sharing widget.
So we talked about how important
sharing is to third
party developers as a growth
channel, so what we want to do
is make that even easier for
your users to access because
right now when you create third
party content in Drive,
you have to go back to the Drive
UI in order to share it
with other people.
We want to take that
functionality of sharing and
be able to bring it directly
into the third party app, so
we've made sharing
now embeddable.
All you have to do is drop in
some JS libraries and do some
client code and users will be
able to access this very
dialogue directly from any
third party experience.
So you're probably thinking
that sounds extremely
complicated and it's going to
make my auth story and my
security story way
more complicated.
The good news is we've taken
care of that for you and it's
really easy to integrate this
directly into your app.
The next thing we're launching
as part of this new SDK is the
ability for third party apps
to open native Google
documents directly from
the Drive UI.
So, for instance, say you're
HelloFax and you would like to
be able to have users
fax Google
documents using your app.
Well, the way it works is Google
documents are able to
export to a number of different
formats, and if
you're HelloFax, all you have to
do is declare your ability
to handle those export formats
and we will do the magic
behind the scenes where we'll
export it to, say, PDF,
HelloFax takes the converted
PDF, and they can fax it.
So that'll be available for all
the native Google document
editors, Google documents,
spreadsheets, presentations,
and so all the conversion
formats that they support
you'll be able to open
as part of your apps.
So all that content that exists
from all these Google
Docs users for years will be
available to you to manipulate
with your appies.
[APPLAUSE]
JOHN DAY-RICHTER:
Aww, thank you.
We like it, too.
JOSH HUDGINS: So now we're going
to show you a little bit
about what's going to be coming
down the pipe here over
the next few months and--
JOHN DAY-RICHTER: Get out of
the way, son, I'm driving.
OK, so here's what's coming soon
to the Google Drive SDK,
I'm very excited about
all this stuff.
Well, both of this stuff.
There's a lot of stuff coming
soon, we're just talking about
two things.
So the first is push
notifications.
If you're using the Google Drive
APIs right now and you
need to show a kind of updated
view of what's going on in a
user's drive, then you are
polling, and that is
inefficient for you, and it's
not great for our system
either, so we are adding real
time notifications.
So now--
[FAINT APPLAUSE]
JOHN DAY-RICHTER: Aww,
there it is.
Yeah.
So you will just set up a kind
of listener and you will get
invalidation notices when the
drive changes, and then you
can go in and ask what's
different, and you'll get it.
And we're going to support a
variety of mechanisms that
will be appropriate for whatever
device you're on, so
if you're trying to do this from
JavaScript, it'll use one
mechanism, if you're trying to
do it from Android, it'll use
a different one, but your code
will be almost the same in all
of those environments.
So it's going to be fairly
consistent and easy to write.
So here's the other thing, which
I'm very excited about.
If you've ever used Google
Docs, there's real time
collaboration where two people
can work on a document at the
same time and they can just see
their changes interposed
together, and it's
really cool.
We saw a demo of it earlier.
We put together our own
demo that we'd like
to share right now.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[TYPING]
JOHN DAY-RICHTER:
Based on a true
story, ladies and gentlemen.
Yes, thank you.
So we are--
yeah.
So what if--
let's go back to the
presentation--
what if you could add those
features to your app, and what
if it was easy?
Well, it turns out that there
are a number of engineers that
worked on Google Docs that are
on the Google Drive SDK team,
and it turns out that if
you're clever, you can
generalize the technology using
Google Docs to work for
any data model.
And so maybe we went ahead
and did that, so
let's go to the demo.
You'll notice this little
paint program,
and isn't it adorable?
I'm going to reload because
the network went down.
OK, so I've got a little thing,
and when you've got a
paint program, you draw
a little man.
And he's happy.
And then, [GASP].
A ghost is drawing in
my same documents.
But it's not, it's Josh, because
this is collaborative.
Now, here's the thing.
The code behind this was
incredibly simple to-- what
are you drawing?
[LAUGHTER]
JOHN DAY-RICHTER: A paramecium
is firing a bow and arrow, oh,
and then you've defaced
my guy.
OK, well, your paramecium
gets a beard, how
you like that punk?
JOSH HUDGINS: I like it.
JOHN DAY-RICHTER: Oh, and also,
let's say that we both
decided to change the
title of this
document at the same time.
You want to get in there?
JOSH HUDGINS: Yeah,
let's do that.
JOHN DAY-RICHTER: Right on
top of my cursor, huh?
Nice.
Jeez.
Thank you for having some
constructive input.
OK, good.
So we're simultaneously
editing on that.
The code to wire up that text
box to be collaborative was
two lines, and if you
add another text
box, it's three lines.
The code to get this paint
thing working--
we'll show it to you in a
second, actually-- but it
turns out it's very, very
simple to set up.
And when you write these apps,
you don't have to know
anything about the operational
transform theory that goes
behind resolving changes,
or any of that stuff.
You write your code like it's a
local JavaScript data model,
you just call like setters and
getter methods, or add and
remove methods if you're dealing
with an array, and it
all just works.
And the only difference between
writing one of these
apps and writing a completely
in-memory JavaScript app is
that you need to add listeners
to your data models because
unlike a traditional data model,
these things might
change because somebody else did
something in the program.
So if you wire up your
listeners-- and you might be
writing your code this
way anyway--
then that's it, you've built
a collaborative app.
Now, this paint program,
although Google doesn't
provide anything like this, it
is the kind of thing Google
might provide.
So we wanted to show you that
this really works with any
data model, so I decided to do
the geekiest thing possible.
So here is a text adventure that
we wrote using this tool,
but it's a text adventure where
you can modify the world
as you play.
So right now we're in the
Drive SDK session.
We appear to be in some sort
of conference venue.
Two geeks drone endlessly on a
stage at one end of the room.
And there is an exit north.
Let's go north.
We're in the hallway.
Because there are sessions going
on, the hallway is a
deserted wasteland.
Tumbleweeds roll past
piles of abandoned
business cards and swag.
And there is an exit south.
There's not a lot going on in
this game, but now, let's have
a collaborator add an
item to the game.
So I've already set this up
so it's easy for me to--
something is different.
Let's look.
The hallway now contains
a disco wand.
Let's take disco wand.
And let's try to use it.
It only works in conference
rooms, well,
let's go back south.
And so the 1970s reign supreme
in the discophonic
phunkisphere.
We feel free and alive for the
first times in our life.
We win the game.
Now, the cool thing here
is that the world was
persistently changing
the whole time.
So when I reload this, it's
using that collaborative data
model, and, again, not doing
anything special, just setting
properties on it.
But when I reloaded, I was back
in the disco because that
state was just automatically
persisted as we changed the
data models.
So these things are really,
really easy and, I dare say,
fun to write.
And if you notice those URLs,
don't bother going to them,
like I said they're only white
listed for Googlers, and they
will be busted.
So, real quick, this is half
of the JavaScript code for
that paint application, which
was not written by me, by the
way, it was written by
Eric Schoeffler on
my team, who's awesome.
I just adapted it to use
the collaboration API.
So this is half of the
code, you're not
expected to read it.
The green stuff is all of the
code that has to do with
collaboration, and I'm being
liberal in determining what
has to do with collaboration
because I included stuff like
setting up listeners and things
like that, which you
might be doing in your
code anyway.
So did you have a question?
JOSH HUDGINS: Well, it looks
like you don't have to add a
lot of client-side code, but
you probably had to write a
ton of server-side
code to make--
JOHN DAY-RICHTER: Oh
yeah, that's right.
Let me show you the server-side
code, oh wait.
There isn't any.
Boom!
Yeah.
[APPLAUSE]
JOHN DAY-RICHTER: Damn.
Thank you.
You can, of course, write
server-side code if you want,
you can write your own JSON
calls, and build your own
servlets, and call out to other
Google APIs, and do
whatever you want.
We don't care, the code
that actually does
this is all in clients.
And so with that, I believe
we're wrapped up.
So thank you, ladies
and gentlemen.
This is Josh, and I'm John.
[APPLAUSE]
JOHN DAY-RICHTER: Now, I believe
most of you are here
for free T-shirts, so let's
start earning those.
Hello.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
You mentioned the addition of
the JavaScript client-side
library in version two.
JOHN DAY-RICHTER: Yep.
AUDIENCE: Is that specifically
for UI in front end, or do you
think we could maybe
use that in OJS?
JOHN DAY-RICHTER:
You know you--
yes.
My DevRel guy is telling me that
that'll work just fine.
[FAINT APPLAUSE]
JOHN DAY-RICHTER: And
everybody loves
it, so thank you.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: So is there an effort
to provide some kind of
application framework to help
us build these great client
apps that have integration with
Drive in collaboration?
There seems to be efforts with
things like Dart and Go in
different languages and GWT--
there's rumors of
it going away.
What's the sustainable path
I should be going down?
JOHN DAY-RICHTER: The APIs that
we are providing right
now, we are very committed
to continuing to support.
So if we've published an
API in your language--
you'll have to check in with our
developer relations people
to be sure what the exact time
horizon we promised to keep
them around in, but we're
following this path.
You have nothing to fear, sir.
AUDIENCE: No, I don't mean the
APIs itself, but as far as
providing like an app framework
that maybe gives me
things like menus, and dialogs,
and all the building
pieces so that I can just start
with a Hello, World! app
and build my specific
functionality.
JOHN DAY-RICHTER: Well, I don't
think that we have any
specific plans to provide a
larger kind of application
development framework, but the
developer sites have a ton of
extremely useful examples
that you can get into.
I think that part of our
philosophy has been, let's
keep our APIs compact so that
it's at your discretion how to
integrate them with the rest of
the tools you like to use.
JOSH HUDGINS: We want to make
sure it's really easy for
existing web apps to add small
footprint amounts of code and
integrate existing investments
with Drive.
JOHN DAY-RICHTER: Yeah, that's
something we really care about
is if you've already invested in
building an app, we want to
make it as easy as possible
for you to add this
functionality in
and not have to
re-engineer your whole thing.
AUDIENCE: OK, thanks.
JOHN DAY-RICHTER: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: One of the things you
mentioned as far as being
able to get data through Google
Docs like export to a
PDF and then pull in like that
fax program, which they
mentioned in the talk
yesterday as well.
Say there's a third party app
that sorts [INAUDIBLE]
proprietary format, but can
also export to PDF or some
intermediate format.
Is there some way you can say
like well, my app can accept
things that can be exported to
PDF and this app can export to
PDF so allow me to
see any apps--
any documents that can possibly
be imported on an app
through that?
JOHN DAY-RICHTER: That's
a great idea.
That's--
JOSH HUDGINS: We've thought
a lot about that.
JOHN DAY-RICHTER: We have
thought a lot about that.
So although, again, we're not
announcing any specific plan
to do that, consider your
suggestion duly noted.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Cross-origin
requests.
We've noticed that several
APIs don't return their
cross-origin header for star,
is that intentional or--?
JOHN DAY-RICHTER: I don't--
you mean APIs as called
from JavaScript?
AUDIENCE: Yes, we have an
application that has an
embedded one could view that
is trying to access some of
the REST APIs in Google Drive.
If that's happening, there's
some sort of buggy behavior
and you should talk to our
developer relations team
because they're telling
us that we
absolutely do support that.
AUDIENCE: Oh OK, yeah, we
have some issues, so--
JOHN DAY-RICHTER: OK, yeah, I
mean, the examples that I
showed you for the collaboration
API are making
CORS requests and
they're working.
AUDIENCE: For your site?
JOHN DAY-RICHTER: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: OK, sure.
Thanks.
AUDIENCE: So this is a little
bit more about Drive itself,
specifically enterprises
and teams and how
you're dealing with--
I want to share, or rather--
if I'm the CIO of an
organization, I want to know
all the files that are being
stored in my user's Google
Apps account.
Is that possible in Google Drive
in general, and then
also from the SDK and API?
JOSH HUDGINS: It's possible with
the API and there are a
lot of really good third party
products that do exactly that
kind of thing, that help you
manage your enterprise-wide
corpora, and they'll give you
all kinds of nice data and
reports on what your user base
is doing and the traffic and
the types of documents and
that sort of thing.
Our general philosophy around
that is we want to give third
parties the ability to build
those exact kind of tools with
our API, and that's what a lot
of this new launch is about if
you have these much more
powerful file system type
operations that will enable
exactly those types of
integrations.
AUDIENCE: And sorry, just
as a follow-up.
JOSH HUDGINS: Sure.
AUDIENCE: For the permissions of
that, does each individual
user have to then enable the
app to have full access
permission, or is it done
similar to like the Apps
Marketplace where it can
just be applied to all
the users at once?
JOSH HUDGINS: Yeah, there are
like admin users that API
calls can [INAUDIBLE] and
that sort of thing.
It doesn't require like a lot
of specific user actions in
order to enable that
type of monitoring.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Great, thanks.
JOSH HUDGINS: Sure.
AUDIENCE: I was wondering, is
there any way to have data
locality like to do some
processing in the Drive?
Like I like being able to share
everything, but if I
want to have some structured
files in the way that I'm used
to and I maybe need to run sed
or grep or something like
that, if I wanted to implement
it, is there any way to do
some processing next to those
files, or would it just be
that the user would say, oh, I
want to run such and such an
AWK command and I would
downloaded it from the web
service, process it, and then
write it back to the Drive?
JOHN DAY-RICHTER: That is
probably how you would want to
do it, especially if you
wanted to do sort of a
massively parallel type thing.
Although you might be interested
in looking at Apps
Script because Apps Script is
capable of doing a lot of the
same analyses that things like
AWK and grep can do, and that
processing is done in the same
data center as the data, so
often you'll get good
performance without having to
download the whole file.
AUDIENCE: Oh, OK.
Great.
AUDIENCE: Two separate
questions.
The first question is on the
Chrome store, you were saying
that anybody can download
any of the apps.
Is there anyway to restrict
the access to those
applications to a specific
corporation
or a specific domain?
JOSH HUDGINS: The only
granularity we have there now
is an individual domain can
either turn apps on or off.
Being able to whitelist or
blacklist specific apps is
still something that's on our
road map that we're moving
towards, but as of right now we
can't give you that level
of granularity in terms
of configuration.
JOHN DAY-RICHTER: That's right,
you can't restrict the
ability to actually install
them, but then you can make
sure that they don't work
on your domain.
And also, if you're writing a
third party app that needs to
be constricted to a certain
group of users, there are
Google APIs that will give you
enough information about the
user for you to do that
on your own app.
So it'll be a bit awkward if a
user does something that they
shouldn't do, but you have the
ability to shut out users that
shouldn't be there.
AUDIENCE: OK.
And the second question is kind
of a follow-up to one of
the previous people.
In one of the previous sessions
someone had mentioned
that you were coming out with
service account capability for
administrative access.
Is there any time frame on
the road map for that?
JOHN DAY-RICHTER: It is coming
out officially soon.
AUDIENCE: OK.
JOHN DAY-RICHTER: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: It seems that you have
some overlap with some of
the features of Cloud Storage,
although it seems almost more
robust than Cloud Storage.
As a developer, should I look
towards using Cloud Storage
for higher performance
or for a task?
I mean, have you benchmarked
it and checked out how it
compares performance-wise
against Cloud Storage?
JOSH HUDGINS: Well, there's not
as many overlapping use
cases, I think, as
you would think.
We're trying to position Drive
to developers as a place you
want to store user data.
If the data's user intermediated
in any way, it
makes more sense to put it there
than in Cloud Storage.
If you want to store assets
that aren't necessarily
related to individual users,
then Cloud Storage is the
product you would want to use.
They have a lot of similar
features, but the use cases, I
think, are fairly different.
AUDIENCE: We actually have an
application that serves user
data, and we use Cloud
Storage for that.
If I migrate to Drive, would I
get a performance hit on the
serving of the data?
JOSH HUDGINS: They use very
similar back end systems.
JOHN DAY-RICHTER: Yeah, I
mean, but they do serve
different purposes in that like
Drive is really best for
file-centric data that you want
users to be able to see
and access anywhere.
So if you care about having
sync clients that
automatically can sync data
to your user's machine or
devices, those kinds of features
in the built in
search probably make Google
Drive a good choice.
But if you're looking for
something that is more a pure
storage back end, then Cloud
Storage is a great choice.
JOSH HUDGINS: And the economics
of the two systems
are drastically different
because in Drive all of the
storage is accounted directly
to users, but if you use
Google Cloud Storage, developers
have to pay for the
storage directly, and if you're
doing that on behalf of
users, then you have to figure
out some way to pass the cost
of your storage onto
individual users.
So if it is user intermediated
in any way, it probably makes
more sense to have
it in Drive.
AUDIENCE: OK, thank you.
AUDIENCE: With the new
Collaboration APIs, will that
support the offline
type capabilities?
JOHN DAY-RICHTER: Yes, there
will be offline.
We are still trying to figure
out whether or not we're going
to handle offline automatically,
or if we'll
give you the ability to get a
version of the data model that
you can flush offline instead.
So if anyone wants to tell me
suggestions about why you
prefer one mode or the other,
I'd love to hear them.
Because that's still
up in the air.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
JOSH HUDGINS: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So along that lines,
in the segue of version
control, do you have any roadmap
plans for how you plan
on integrating previous versions
of documents being
released into a changed
management system?
JOHN DAY-RICHTER: Are you
talking about for
Collaboration API or for
Drive in general?
AUDIENCE: Drive in general, I
guess, but also in terms of
how it might affect API.
JOHN DAY-RICHTER:
Well, let's see.
For Drive, when you upload a
file, you can choose to--
you're always uploading a new
revision of the file.
And then you have the ability
to say that this is a pinned
revision, and so that revision
is guaranteed not to get
cleaned up.
If you upload a revision that
you choose not to pin, it
means that later revisions might
cause earlier revisions
to get deleted if they're ones
that you didn't care about.
But history is kind
of built right in
when blobs are uploaded.
AUDIENCE: So on the question
where they had the offline and
they demoed in the keynote
the changes made
automatically applied.
How does it affect--
is it time stamped for
clobbering other users'
offline versions?
JOHN DAY-RICHTER: In his
particular demo, he used
Google Docs, and Google Docs
uses something like the
Collaboration API, so that
stored the data in a temporary
browser cache, and then it used
the same protocol that it
uses to sync in real time
to get all those
things back into sync.
So Google Docs and the
Collaboration API are very
tightly revisioned, so almost
everything you do gets a
revision in a history log.
AUDIENCE: OK.
JOHN DAY-RICHTER: Yeah
AUDIENCE: I really liked the
demo earlier in the keynote
and searching inside
your image files.
You guys have any plans of
indexing and searching custom
formats delivered by the apps?
JOSH HUDGINS: So what we do
right now is we expose through
the API the ability
for you to set the
indexable text yourself.
So whatever you feel like is
important to allow users to
search for within your data, you
can pass that directly to
Drive via the API and then when
users search for things
in that body of text, they'll
show up directly in the UI
under search.
AUDIENCE: Does this include also
searching from the API?
JOSH HUDGINS: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So say I'm building
a voting application and I
want people to vote between
carrot sticks and cookies.
And I share my ballot with
Cookie Monster, and Cookie
Monster is a pretty
savvy programmer.
What's to prevent Cookie Monster
from using the RESTful
APIs to vote for cookies
2,000 times.
JOHN DAY-RICHTER: Well, nothing
because Cookie Monster
was given a very high level of
access to that document.
So I suggest that in a situation
where you need to
really have more granular
control of how data is
written, that you don't
want to use the
Google Doc sharing model.
Because there's no write-only
access to a doc really.
I guess you could use forms
for something like that.
But the point is if you want
to expose things to Sesame
Street characters and in this
very volatile political
context, I suggest that you
build a strongly authenticated
front end and write to a back
end where there's no direct
user access at all.
AUDIENCE: OK.
JOHN DAY-RICHTER: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So there's a natural,
I guess match,
between Docs and Drive.
And I think your Docs files
automatically show up in Drive.
JOSH HUDGINS: Right.
AUDIENCE: What about Contacts
and Calendar, is that--
I don't know if they show
up automatically, I
don't think they do--
and what is the plan for that?
Because I don't want to write
some sync client that maybe
shows these things up in the
thing when Google is going to
be releasing that
relatively soon.
JOSH HUDGINS: Contacts and
Calendar events will stay in
their own product data silos,
we're not going to attempt to
surface those in Drive.
We do have some plans around
other types of internal
product integrations, but those
are still pretty far
down the roadmap list.
JOHN DAY-RICHTER: But if you
want to write that app, you
have all the tools you
need to do it.
It's possible to just write
short cuts into Google Drive
that when clicked go out to your
site, where then you can
fetch whatever other Google
entity you want and show it
using their APIs.
So yeah, go start yourself a
million dollar business, sir.
AUDIENCE: OK, thanks.
Well, I already have, but.
JOHN DAY-RICHTER: Oh.
Can I have some?
Yes, sir?
AUDIENCE: Just thinking about
the sharing and also
notifications, is there any
plans to kind of [INAUDIBLE]
share and could do like a
workflow, sort of route a
document to Person A, if they
approve it, it's going to
route to Person B, and they'll
get some kind of notification
of the sharing.
JOHN DAY-RICHTER: Well,
we don't have anything
like that right now.
JOSH HUDGINS: So you have a
couple different options.
We are linking more and more
actions that occur in Drive
into wiring them into our
scripting language, Apps
Script, so you could build
a custom workflow
solution that way.
And then we're giving you a
whole lot of tools via the
same events and with the
API, so you can--
like via the notifications that
we were talking about you
can monitor for certain events,
you'll get push
notifications that can perform
actions using the API.
So a lot of ways to build a
custom workflow solution, but
we're not going to overlay that
type of functionality
directly in the product
itself.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thank you.
JOHN DAY-RICHTER: And
we are over time.
So thank you so much
for coming, and
T-shirts are in the back.
[APPLAUSE]